I have always been interested in the man
dying cosmology which man die ins are a
sect that rose probably around Jerusalem
somewhere in the early Christian era
very rich very old tradition and they
have the notion in their cosmology of a
messiah which they called the secret
Adam and the secret Adam will come at
the end of the world and the man dyin
notion of what's going on is that we all
have a soul made of light and the light
is trapped in matter this universe is
not our home this universe is a a kind
of hell in which we wander and the
purpose of religion is to teach people
about the light inside themselves and
how to gather it together and how to get
it out of this universe and into our
rightful home which is a much better
place so the man dyin
eschaton is that this Messiah called the
secret Adam will come but what's unusual
is that the secret Adam teaches no
message has no point of view but builds
a machine they specifically say this
builds an object of some sort and the
object operationally could be described
as a light pump the light pump of the
man died and Messiah then gathers the
life of all souls that have lived or are
living and transmits the light first to
the moon then to beam this then to the
Sun and then out of this universe
entirely to the higher and hidden
presence of the all-father
[Music]
[Music]
you